[Music]
well welcome back to another addy hour
episode of course it's my pleasure to be
able to continue these conversations on
a lot of different topics which i feel
are really important for so many aspects
of our lives and today really iron to be
able to jump into a topic around
children and youth so really think about
the next generation and again something
i think is very relevant for all of us
no matter at what level we interact with
those in the generations coming up so
today i'm honored to be able to welcome
dr michelle borba who is an
internationally renowned educational
psychologist who has published over 20
books
one of those books includes unselfie why
empathetic kids succeed and are all
about the world
michelle is an expert in parenting
bullying and character development and
she's spoken to over one million
participants on five continents so
someone who has definitely gotten around
and just really use that to inform her
work she's a regular nbc contributor who
appears regularly on today she's also
been featured as an expert on dateline
the view dr phil nbc nightly news fox
and friends dr oz and the early show
among many others she also has a
forthcoming book which we'll be talking
about as well and she lives in palm
springs california with her husband and
it's also the mother of three grown sons
so that's one thing that was intriguing
to me as well given your work i would
love to hear you know to even meet your
sons at some point but that's that's a
little bit of a tangent but again i just
want to welcome dr michelle bourbon to
the adiabatic thank you i have been so
looking forward to this i'm going to
hire you as my new pr firm
i would take that out
well thanks so much for being here and
again the work you do is so important um
but as my listeners thank you oh i
really appreciate that definitely
appreciate that um as my listeners know
as well one of the things that we really
uh just value on this podcast is the
opportunity to kind of peel back the
layers as it were even as we bring in so
many experts so i did want to start out
just asking you how you're doing at this
moment with everything that's going on
in our world especially with the things
that have been unfolding um in ukraine
and russia as well
well i think i've been sobbing my way
through the last three days with ukraine
i just uh the abomination is just
extraordinary i have friends who adopted
children from ukrainian uh orphanages
the biggest concern right now is trying
to get a hold of them and um they're
trying to
there's so many hundreds of kids under
the age of even four
trying to figure out how to get them
enough food in order to get them across
a 20 mile a 20 hour walk
so
that's been really hard uh but you know
when i the other thing though i have to
keep telling myself is
look to the other side otherwise i get
too caught in putin and i looked at the
other side and i saw
images of hundreds of shoes in pole and
waiting for kids when they got off the
train
hate shoes or the people in these other
countries with signs saying here i am
i've got a place for you to stay that
kind of a thing it's just it gives you
that there's that evil but wow is there
humanity if we look for it yeah i think
that's so well said we're seeing both
sides of humanity in that way and
intense i appreciate you just sharing
that honestly too on you know how you're
navigating that just to have
a good place for yourself as well um and
i know that's something that's near and
dear to your heart and something i've
heard you speak about as well even just
in terms of
compassion fatigue and i was just
curious about how for any who i'm sure a
lot of people have heard that term but
how's that actually relate to the moment
that we're in as you shared so so
honestly about
i think we're all feeling it it's
absolutely if there was one universal
diagnosis it would be compassion fatigue
and what is it we all need relationships
we all crave empathy and when social
distancing kicked in and we all had to
be face to face and we couldn't see our
family and friends that's what
rejuvenates us in the other hand what
happened was stress starts to build and
when stress keeps building and
uncertainty is there you where you often
dial your empathy down and the outcome
is compassion fatigue
so when you see yourself being kind of
oh i'm not quite already there or your
energy level is low
uh what i'm really trying to do is read
books that i could get into and
absolutely love i just finished the
lincoln highway and i fell in love with
an eight-year-old kid named billy oh my
god
fun movies that you can see good side i
watch the news content and try to turn
it off so that i can see a different
view
and i have been doing a lot of zooming
with people that i just really enjoy
talking to because it helps me build up
i think we all need to do that find out
what works for you because you have to
keep your empathy up and that's
stressful down yeah
yeah so important and i feel like a lot
of ways we've been trying to be creative
about that as well
some of the topics that we've been
talking about on this podcast have been
around just the importance of social
bonding and how that activates oxytocin
in our brains and all those pieces and
you know whether that's still there on
zoom or not but there's just a different
energy that comes from being in person
but at the same time like you said there
are opportunities to be able to connect
with people in ways that we hadn't done
that before so appreciate you sharing
how you're
navigating that journey as well we just
had to put our creativity into it well
that didn't work so what are we going to
do instead and if we keep just keep
looking for the other options uh i think
that's how we thrive yeah yeah
and thrive i'm glad you used that word
because that's something we'll
definitely come back to
maybe that was intentional maybe not but
as we think about your new book as well
part of my that's part of my vocabulary
what are we gonna do to keep on doing
and raising thrivers yeah so important
before we jump there i just also want to
hear a little bit about your journey um
for those who may be familiar with you
and those who aren't familiar with you
how did you what what started this
passion to get into this area of child
development and so many directions that
you've taken it
absolute fluke i was a i was a history
major wow and i came home to i didn't
expect that no i came home to interview
my dad or just be with my dad from
college for a weekend and i'd never
forget it you will appreciate this my
dad was calm he was cool you know the
world war ii veteran the superintendent
he published books he was quite
accomplished but he was so upset that
day and he was holding a newsweek
magazine and he was pacing the floor he
looked at me and he didn't expect my
visit and the cover of the magazine was
the first three years of a child's life
make or break them he turned to me
pointed to it and said don't buy into
this michelle because if this were true
i'd be dead today
now i sat there with my mouth open
because i didn't know anything about my
dad's parents he had passed away i never
met my grandparents he sat me down and
he said this is what happened to me his
parents apparently came over very
destitute no english from italy tried
desperately to be able to jumpstart and
wanted to give their kids the best they
could my my dad was the youngest of five
but my father grandfather went and
became a cold miner and then died when
my dad was two and the only way that his
extremely loving mother could afford the
children and keep them alive was to put
them in an orphanage so he said my dad
said okay now i'm in an orphanage my mom
is destitute i didn't know what was
going on but he said it was the people
who saved me the nuns had such empathy
for me michelle that was the first thing
those nuns when they released me my mom
got a little more money it was a local
librarian she'd sneak books to me danny
would read this the the neighbor next
door would help me rake and give me a
little bit extra money a teacher would
pull me aside and say i think you could
be a good writer he said my proudest
moment was when i got my scholarship
from stanford and uc berkeley to walk in
and say thank you very much
don't buy into it michelle people can
make or break your life i went back and
changed my major to child development
there found this amazing piece of
research by emmy werner and that started
my whole career emmy warner
substantiated what my dad said she
started to interview uh oh gosh
40 uh just for 40 years she studied the
same 700 children who shouldn't have
made it
extreme adversity in their life but
one-third of them even by their teens
years was bouncing back and she
discovered the same thing
caring people in their lives that would
what my dad said and then somebody had
taught them protective buffers or coping
strategies and as a result they made it
and that changed my whole career okay
that is true that we got to get this
nation out to people yeah that's such a
powerful story and i love that it has a
family connection
um as well and it sounds like just in
that moment it was a shift and a passion
that emerged it was an amazing shift and
later on he said michelle you should be
a special ed teacher that's how i ended
up in special ed everything i learned
from every part of my so-called career
was from kids
it wasn't the textbook it was the kids
who convinced me boy this is doable
stuff yeah the hands-on real life
experience
wow wow definitely appreciate that and
as you were as you were getting into the
work um how do people respond to you
where people
because in the same way it seems like
there could be a mixed reaction that
either people would be really excited
about it or did people ask you why why
this route
why this route you know interestingly
enough you're probably one of the few
people that ask why this routes
very much
i my goal is it's funny i just took a
very slow path of a trajectory whenever
a phone call would ring or something i
went into a different director i got my
master's in learning disabilities and
then i i found this passion for
educational psychology that's where i
got my doctorate i never planned to
write a book but i had one of my
professors tell me i should and then
once i wrote the book i never planned to
be a speaker but somebody called up and
said we need you to speak so it was
saying yes to all of these little
avenues along the way and i'm so glad i
did yeah and it seems like it's tapped
into your passion that was already there
too and so in a sense you were poisoned
ready for the opportunities that came
because you're already following that
passion which i think is really
encouraging to hear yeah on how critical
it is to find that passion what's your
joy what you just absolutely love to do
and
just to helping kids and working with
families no matter where i am is is my
passion and i've had the absolute
amazing opportunity to work on uh i
think of five continents now i'm up to
23 countries
and what i've learned from it is no
matter where you are
everybody has the same loves and
concerns and desires for their kids
so it works no matter where we are let
someone work together we're just all
neighbors yeah that's so important
especially with everything we've been
walking through in the last few years
too would you say that was that a
surprise here do you think that you
expected to see that that commonality um
well travel has broken every stereotype
i had of life and we could all travel
more
yeah it helps you no matter where you
are
uh just be far more open and realize
they're just like me no matter where i
am i don't care if it's religion
education uh you know race color creed
oh my gosh people are wonderful with my
best friends i've got them all over the
world and um i just got another call
from abu dhabi this morning and said can
you come back oh i'd love to come back
wow
yeah that's so powerful i mean it speaks
to this the global community that we
have in a sense too and even as you were
sharing about your dad's story just
making me think about the community that
he had around him all those people who
were sewing into his life in different
ways and giving him encouragement the
empathy the empowerment i think that's
that's so critical and so encouraging to
hear that the way that you've built that
into your work even as one individual
who has traveled to all these places
learned so much and is really sharing
that with so many of us
i love susan tinker's book the village
effect because she said if you really
want to boost empathy which is to me the
social glue that holds us all together
remember that villages of about 150
people are the
maximum of what kids really need in
order to create that community and what
we've done is we we've busted the
villages and we're these huge huge
suburban areas one of my favorite things
to do is is as i'm driving from i don't
care if it's sri lanka or new york
i purposely go through an area and i can
go from a rural area drive through and i
watch the facial expressions and they
look like they're happy and then all of
a sudden as i go into a bigger area in
an urban area a little bit more stress
comes in so maybe the first thing is we
just got to capture each other and
realize we are the support system let's
get back to what we all need for optimum
mental health and as parents let's also
look at what we're modeling are we
modeling thinking outside the box
exposing our children to differences
letting them be exposed to how many
wonderful other opportunities they are
um you know there's a great study that
also said during the pandemic the kids
who seem to fare a little better were
the kids who didn't take the bus from
new york to their school but walk
through the park in order to get to
their school just those simple ordinary
things um i'll mention one thing when i
was writing on resilience i've been
trying to study this for 40 years after
my dad it's one of the best books i also
read was by anne mastin she's from
university of minnesota and what she did
was she discovered when she did the same
thing of kids growing up in extreme
adversity is it ordinary things can make
extraordinary differences on children's
lives and when i looked at what do you
mean by the ordinary things like the
walk through the park
like prayer like a sense of humor uh
like a some kind of a talent or a hobby
or an interest
knowing who i've got one friend and i
looked at that and said that's what
seems to be a problem what we've got is
ordinary things
being removed a lot from our children's
lives and maybe we just need to reboot
yeah and uh it's not just the gpa that's
going to help our kids in this world
it's those ordinary things that help
fill them and are going to be really
good decompressors
along with life yeah
so so many things that you said that i'd
love to unpack and i'll pick a few but
even as you're talking about those
ordinary things no small things i mean
as a neuroscientist even thinking about
what we understand about the brain and
having the breaks and just the things in
our environment that can bring us
pleasure and even as we can engage and
our day-to-day activities how can that
really can help us navigate and just
have a place of mental
health wellness and i think oftentimes
we talk about that in adult circles we
don't always i think as much as we need
to
really think about that for children and
youth where it's even that much more
important especially from a
developmental standpoint so it's great
great that you've been paying attention
to that and to elevate that as well oh
you know i one of the things that when
you ask what am i looking forward to
right now is i'm finally being able to
get back on the road and go and visit
schools
the best thing i get to do before i talk
to the big school district is do focus
groups with teens oh my gosh they just
are so extraordinary once they know that
whatever they say it's going to be uh
there's no judgment just tell me so i've
been trying to figure out and ask them
you know what's causing all of this
stress
and what they're the solutions for it
and one kid i just came from college
station texas he said we are so stressed
but the thing is that nobody's teaching
us how to de-stress
and it doesn't isn't something you learn
on a worksheet and it's not like a
one-time health unit the big thing you
guys you guys have got to do is give us
a repertoire of stuff and then we choose
what works for us and then we have got
to practice that over and over and over
and over until we can do it without you
oh my gosh wow that's so insightful
so if you're gonna make us do that deep
breathing stuff that's cool but don't
just tell us what it is
every single day we should practice that
maybe two minutes a day um
yeah that's exactly we could be doing
that at home when we say we're so tired
no we got two minutes a day just
practice one thing until it becomes a
new family habit i i say that one
because one of the coolest places i ever
worked was on army basis
18 of them and the commanders kept
telling me you should go talk to the
navy seals i said wise is because we're
retraining them to get through some
really tough adverse times and i'm going
that's for sure so when i asked the navy
seals i said what are you guys doing i
said three things and you better tell
kids this because this is really helping
us and it's actually proven to rewire
our brains okay what's one we figure out
what our stress signs are and we start
pointing it out to each other we don't
wait to the meltdown we we point them
out hey you start grinding your teeth or
you start going like this or i can see
you know your heart popping up and down
we could do that to our kids not that
you're going to get time out but just
have you noticed that right before you
go to do the time test this is what you
do then they say we tell ourselves chill
out or relax and then we take a one two
breath
slow two breath from our abdomen nothing
new
that is slow do breath way like we're
riding up an elevator keep focusing on
the breath hold it and then slowly let
it out so the exhale is twice as long as
the inhale you see berkeley says that's
exactly what works yeah why do we teach
that to kids doesn't cost a dime yeah
yeah so important and on that no i'm
curious because even as you're talking
about the focus groups with the teens it
seems like there's a push and pull i
mean even the you know the kids that
i've talked to in schools and having
kids myself too it seems like sometimes
there's just different places that
people are at so i'm curious what your
view is of where those mental health
conversations are for kids because
sometimes i get the sense
that the kids are thinking about it more
than the administrators or their
teachers and not to downplay the efforts
of the administration teachers are
putting in but seems like sometimes
there's a disconnect almost as if
kids and youth are more ready to move
into it than we give them credit for now
i guess i'm answering the question as
i'm saying if i'm curious if that's been
your perspective
and i think that's what's happening
right now is the pandemic aftermath we
knew that it was going to be a stressful
for us all but now when we're looking at
okay now we can get back to normal i
think we ought to put the red flag up
and go really what's going on with the
kids the first thing that the kids are
saying that i had seen but they're now
admitting their motivation is lower
their focusing abilities are lower and
this is the top performing kids these
are we're more irritable we can't handle
the stress we're not sleeping as well as
we used to so when you put all that
together the last thing you're going to
be able to do is they sit there for
three hours and keep going they said
you've got to reinvent a little bit that
homework load are just astronomical on
us we really are having a tough time
uh and we really need to know
feel comfortable going and talking to
the counselors many of the counselors
have been they're wonderful they said
but they've been they've been really
helping us prior to coming in
with our gpas and our getting to college
you want us to now open up and tell them
how upset we are or how much in pain we
are we get to build trust
i i love the comments they came up with
because they're just you know you could
read any psychology book and it's
exactly the same exactly yeah i think
the first thing is we are seeing a
regression in behavior patterns if i was
to ask any uh teacher or counselor or
headmaster what are you seeing kid
regression more disrespect is coming up
more
the whole society is disrespectful the
adults have been behaving very badly i
think it's spilling over to the kids
the second thing is uh inability to
really uh that motivation and the
perseverance isn't there but in all
fairness you can't have the perseverance
unless you have the self-control unless
you have the confidence and they all
kind of work together as you know so
yeah have to start with where the kids
are yeah i think that's so so well said
one of the episodes we had recently was
again more of the causal but someone
who's an expert in trauma-informed
teaching and learning too and just
acknowledging all the things that the
kids have gone through and how like you
said that's going to affect their
actions in the classroom but not
ignoring that and trying to just push
beyond but being aware of that too what
do you say to parents and teachers
though because i know sometimes the
comments that comes back the comments
that come back people say well i'm here
to teach i'm not a therapist i don't
know how to navigate this and so even
though as you're saying appropriately we
need to push beyond just the gpa piece
sometimes people find that very
difficult to break outside of that do
you have tips that you try and share
with them in those situations for
instance i'm going to indiana tomorrow
and what i'm trying to do is when i talk
to the teachers it's all about i know
you're teaching don't stop the lesson
but let's find simple little ways to
weave in these things for instance
as you're talking you know that your
kids attentions fans i don't care if
they're 17 or 3 or shorter so take brain
breaks and that is don't talk for 50
minutes instead let's talk for 10
minutes and then let's take a 30 second
turn to your partner what's one thing
you just heard you're gonna get more
retention from your kids or just pick up
your pencil and draw one little thing
that the teacher just said that's one
thing one of the best things i've ever
seen is quiet time that's being done in
the oakland schools what they did
brilliantly will shave off one minute of
each class time just one minute of each
class time now you have five minutes at
the beginning of every single day
five minutes at the beginning of every
single day
every kid in the entire school and the
teachers do one-two breathing uh you can
veg if you want to half the kids are
sleeping for the first time
you can choose meditation if you choose
to but here's the fabulous thing they've
been tracking it parties are going down
suspensions are going down behavior
problems are going down test scores went
through the roof they did absolutely
nothing different than let's just focus
on what the kids seem to need let's
teach them how
let's have a counselor come in and show
you how to do a one-two breath and it
made mind-boggling like differences so
it's not that you're stopping teaching
exactly you're going with where your
students are
trying to get them more engaged because
they're not they're also by the way more
risk adverse they're afraid to raise
their hands they're they're really
social anxieties up with their kids
because they've been facing a screen for
so long
so a simple thing i also tell a teacher
you can tell them at home
first thing is mary bud row brilliant
researcher she said you want to ask a
question ask the question then stop and
pause and don't say anything for at
least three seconds because the average
one of us says something immediately so
what's the answer if you wait three
seconds you'll get every kid to say
something the kid who wouldn't have said
anything's gonna open his mouth and say
you know maybe a word the other kid who
would have said something is now gonna
give you a dissertation but it's time to
wait and think can be critical and the
final thing is our expectations parents
it's like a rubber band your goal is to
figure out what your kid is capable of
right this minute if you don't know ask
the teacher
line your expectations up and then
gently keep stretching him
gently don't snap him because you'll
snap his spirit but you keep stretching
one step more and one step more in one
step
just little things that's using the
research that don't mean it's another
program but it means we can make a
difference on how our kids are more
engaged better performers better
behaviors and their confidence will also
yeah that's so powerful on so many
levels i mean just to hear the outcomes
too even though
some of those things weren't the focus
but just having that five minute pause
time how it had so many
positive effects in so many ways i'm
curious you know as i'm listening to you
talk through those things and because a
lot of what we've talked about has been
on college and university campuses
i'm curious how much there's a resetting
of expectations because you even talked
about that from parents but one thing
i've also noticed is sometimes
helping students reset their own
expectations because sometimes they're
setting them too high yes or something a
pre-covered something that's not
attainable falling short of it feeling
guilty and anxious they didn't meet
those goals
and still and then getting stuck in a
cycle where they get further and further
away from those are there any aspects of
that that you also see um at younger
ages as well even as you've talked about
the parents saying expectations what
about the kids themselves
oh all across the board their
expectations they say fascinating of
what do you need i guess the first thing
is what do you need from your parents
the number one thing i get from the kids
oh is i would you please tell them to
just say that you love me for who i am
and don't quit asking me about the grade
because we are so worried about letting
our parents down i know they're worried
about us but we are really really
scrambling to get it together if you
take one step more you can teach goal
setting to kids but goal setting is
don't aim to hear a good coach of an
olympic athlete never said you're going
to get a gold medal tomorrow yeah what's
your time today and then you teach them
one step more and one step more and one
step more or you have a child who's
overwhelmed oh my gosh because of the
anxiety so what you do there is you tell
them to chunk the task and that is let's
look at it all okay don't go worried
about the whole thing let's do the first
row or the second row or is there one
thing on that whole sheet that is your
stumbler
this example i talked piano as a kid and
mr white drove me to early retirement on
the piano you still remember his name
oh my god mr white if you made one
mistake wherever you were you had to
start all over again so what i would do
was only focus on the mistake my stress
level was so high that i started to hate
piano bless miss thompson she was my
next teacher and what she had is a whole
different approach
he'd identified my stumbler
so one little thing that's getting in
your way michelle let's just practice
that little bar over and over and over
now you're fine now start at the
beginning well now i'm relaxed and
that's what a good coach does yeah they
never say you might as well quit you
can't do it right no let's look at the
video well your foot's going the wrong
way let's just practice your foot going
that way see
the goal is to take all those little
evidence-based strategies not them all
or your kid will never let you read
another book
one little thing at a time
what works for you until
you can teach your child to do it on
their own because the one thing i have
discovered about resilient children is
they have agency
they don't wait for us to do it
they finally figure out the strategies
and that's what we've got to help our
kids learn is you've got it but here's
the strategy that'll help you get it
you'll practice the practice until you
can do it all your own then they'll use
it the rest of their lives yeah that's
so i mean so many practical pieces there
that all seem like they're a cultural
shift i mean like you said they're all
evidence-based but because of the
performance being so ingrained in our
culture i think it's that much more
difficult at times
well i think the first step you know is
you can't change your parenting or your
teaching or anything unless you
understand the why
and i always tell the school i said the
most wonderful thing you could do is it
won't take any more than a minute is
give every kid a survey and just fill
out three things what's the one thing
you wish the teachers would what do you
appreciate about the teachers what's the
one thing you you wish appreciate about
your parents or wish they would do
what's the one feeling that you're
having right now
an
anxiety stress overwhelmed always come
up on the feeling the one thing they
appreciate about the teachers it makes
them cry every time i just did this with
jacksonville florida and they the kids
came out these were teens
the lunch lady i love her because she
sings all day and i walk into the lunch
room and she's singing the custodian
because he says have a good one spike
you're gonna do it the teacher who waits
for me at the door and says
simple little things
and then i i looked at the parents and i
was
frankly i was saying oh my gosh
what's the one thing you appreciate your
parent or your family i can't tell you
how many times my dog came up on the
list
my dog that my mom drives me to school
it wasn't the things we said
and we've got to maybe have some empathy
for our children
because they're really hurting right now
yeah
you know
that surveys are so i mean even just the
naming it as you mentioned which goes
back to on the one hand naming the
things that are challenging but naming
the things that are giving life and
giving support at the same time so
important so
i also i'm going to throw a little bit
of an audible because this is a question
that i've been curious about for some
time um obviously i know you focus on
the child development but one thing that
again just talking to kids that seems to
come up sometimes as i hear them kind of
talking about scenarios in the schools
and again like the neuroscientists in me
automatically goes on to think well
these teachers are spread very thin and
i'm not sure the teachers are actually
attentive to their own stressors
and irritants and things like that so is
that something that comes up in
conversation even though i know you
focus on the child development
awareness for the adults who are in the
classroom a critical critical comment
because first of all we are losing
an enormous amount of teachers who are
retiring if there's one thing every one
of us should do is write a thank you
note to a teacher because
the reason that they got into teaching
is because they love children that want
to make a difference
just writing them a thank you is one of
the best ways to reduce burnout second
of all is at the end of every one of my
speeches i spend 30 minutes talking
about now what are you going to do take
care of yourself
what's your one go-to that works for you
i would suggest at schools that you do
more uh sunshine calls just uh just
taking time for each other collegiality
finding a support network what is
working for you and in some cases the
counselor has a before school yoga group
that doesn't mean all teachers are going
to do it for some teachers uh they say
they really love
books bibliotherapy getting into the
shoes of a character who's been through
a tough time and coming out to the other
side reading the book educated can be
enormous
malala's books can be extraordinary of
here's a kid who endured and got through
it helps the teacher realize resilience
is something that you're not born with
you can acquire it and we can help our
children and it's doable but once they
begin to realize you can do it i
remember when i was writing the book
thrivers each chapter has a real story
about somebody who endured and made it
to
an extraordinary tough time and i
remember when i was writing the chapter
on empathy i was reading about elizabeth
smart
here is a girl who went through nine
months of absolute terror
kidnapped uh
a knife uh in her bedroom and then
horrific horrors of horse but the one
chapter that just it was the stop moment
how did she endure it she said
it was the second day of captivity when
all of a sudden i remembered something
my mother said to me
she came crystal clear into my head and
she said elizabeth no matter what
remember i will always love you no
matter whatever happens i'm always there
for you and i said if my mother is
always going to love me for who i am i'm
going to be able to get through it she
says that gave me the fortitude to keep
going wow
wow
that's so powerful yeah so i think we
forget those ordinary things and it's
like go home and hug your kid but tell
them i'm here for you no matter what
happens i love you for who you are yeah
that's so so easy for us to to slip out
of that i think that ties everything
together what you've been talking about
both from the kids and from our
expectations as we all kind of get
spread then
in those places so
wow just i mean i just feel like there's
even just a pause there and just really
take that in because i think that
comment even of itself can go such a
long way
but the other thing which really stand
up stands out from what you're talking
about it's just the learning that
happens the learning of the resilience
now you know you talked about that with
empathy as well
so i'd also want to get to your new book
but maybe to park on this empathy piece
for a little bit and just have you
elaborate on what you've learned about
really
teaching that and how that can be
developed and kind of stick for the long
term what are some of the principles
that have come up in your work i think
it was dealing with um
well it was once again a moment that
just changed my life it was uh sitting
on a bench in the cambodian killing
fields
and it it was i had a and i was crying
so hard i had a nosebleed because there
in front of me was a tree with these
little ribbons on it and each ribbon
stood for a child who had been
slaughtered on that tree because they
were crying
next to me was a monolith a five stories
high of skulls and i could not believe
anybody could be so evil and that was
that president was a former teacher
who set the evil so that's doable i i
couldn't believe it i happened to walk
off the killing fields and there was a
little teeny uh table that was selling a
few books
and there was my oh my gosh
i picked it up it was by samuel allener
one of the most amazing social
psychologists his family had been
slaughtered in germany during the
holocaust had a perfect woman just
didn't know anyone
or him
samuel was 12 at the time
her name was bowinda she said samuel
come in here i need to save you run as
fast as you can his family went off to a
death camp she saved his life and now
the entire rest of his life is trying to
figure out
what makes the windows of the world not
the evil what flips the other side and
what he did was extraordinary he's
interviewed hundreds of rescuers
christians during world war ii who's who
risked their life to save a jewish
people
why he said and the commonality of each
one of them were three things i call
them the three e's
every one of them said it was how i was
raised
whoa how were you raised the first thing
was example they saw my dad or i saw my
mom she always really was the example of
empathy or kindness
the second thing was expectations in our
family you were expected to be kind you
were expected to do good the third one
was experiences my dad would would
walk it my mom would say it but then we
did experiences so we would deliver
overcoats to a needy family or we'd bake
cookies to the neighbor next door those
three things started to build empathy so
each person said i saw myself as a
caring person what the parents were
doing was changing the child's mindset
yeah so now they see themselves as a
caring person you act how you see
yourself to be and i think what we've
done is we put so much of our mindset
into the gpa and the test score that
when the kid comes home we rarely say
what good thing did you do as opposed to
what grade did you get
it doesn't mean you're going to stop
asking uh are you studying your hardest
but it also means this what is i expect
you to do
my the lesson from it all is that
empathy can be cultivated and the
research now is clear that our we're our
children are hardwired for it
but unless we really make it a little
more intentional in today's world in
particular it's going to lie dormant and
i swear after after especially after two
years of physical distancing and looking
at a screen as opposed to face to face
because the pathway to empathy is
looking at someone and going how would
she fail how do i feel
that emotional literacy piece starts the
trajectory towards i'm going to reach
out and help
so those are the things that you learned
and that's why i wrote a selfie i went
okay if this is doable then what are the
habits that we can start teaching and
let's make it easy
um and i one of the most critical ones
is besides instilling in your child to
caring mindset we need to talk feelings
far more naturally to our kids yeah we
can watch inside out with our older kids
we can say how are you doing today we
can say sit here and watch dad's face
and when he walks in and you'll know if
this is a good time to ask him for the
allowance or not can be extremely
wonderful moments but
you can also for some children they're a
little nervous about saying the emotion
so you can do what an er doctor says and
he always says how bad's the pain
showing with your fingers a zero issue
could be asleep it's so you're so
relaxed a seven you're about ready to
explode because the pain is so bad but
you can do that with your children your
children can give you i'm at a three mom
thank you for telling me sweetie let's
figure out how to get it to a two or a
one
you know
it's that empathy piece of us trying to
empathize with our kids
starter point then we start helping them
learn emotions we start helping them not
see it in themselves but how would you
feel if that happened to you what is she
in order to feel better what can you do
you watch tv it's just gloriously just
horrific stuff but you can also say what
can we do to help
yeah that's a good idea i know you're
really upset by that but let's go
collect some that's gonna keep a box by
your back door
it's a charity box for your family and
it's for gently used toys and books and
whatever backpacks and each time it's
filled your family not you mom dad your
family delivers it
to someone in need every child said it
was the look in the other person's eye
that said i got to keep doing this
that's so so well sent i mean i love so
many pieces of that just the three e's
that you share too i mean even thinking
about the example and the experience
together because as you're talking about
parents really tuning in with their
children but then also having times to
say as parents well this is what i'm
feeling in this moment and to have the
kids also learn from that example and
again you know i keep kind of moving
back to the college sphere because
that's the space that i live in but i've
even seen that on campus in a lot of
ways too with a lot of the social
justice issues that have been going
on with students who have said oh i've
never heard my professors actually talk
about
their own struggles with this or create
the space
to have those conferences so as those
things are beginning to happen it seems
like even though this is a later
developmental stage there's places for
people to actually build community and
empathy with one another because they
can now both see where they're coming
from and then tie into so many of those
practical outcomes that you're talking
about as well
well i think the trajectory from me to
we and that's where we're aiming for oh
i hope we're aiming for a society is to
listen to other people's stories to
realize how much we have in common with
them when a child says he's different no
let's find out how we're the same
it's too often that sped apart and we're
becoming so divisive as a group we can't
we've got to figure out look at the kind
of books you're reading to your children
make sure that you're reading different
genders different races different
incomes different possibilities because
books
books literary fiction are known to be
able to open up your
empathy ah okay you they also help you
in terms of learning but you find the
right book that's why wonder is one of
the most popular books for children
right now because they feel the great
one
yeah i ask middle school kids what's the
one book that teachers should always
always always help kids read and i'm
blown away that they say the outsiders i
want that's 50 years old why i love
their answer because we've got to
understand what it feels like to be
excluded
how glorious to have that as an answer
and that means that you're exposing kids
and then you're doing something
wonderful like you did having the space
to be able to talk about it
have those dialogues where a kid knows
it's okay to open up and yeah and to be
assertive because that's another trait
of resilient children they have voice
yeah so important i mean just as we're
talking this is one of those i'm
definitely have to go back to this
because i think you're bringing so many
things to life and like you said there's
so much evidence for it but to just to
hear it in this context and be reminded
i think is so important there's so many
practical pieces that we can pull out of
it thank you
well that was the goal the goal was
really after listening to my dad i saw
two huge needs and i think it was again
i started to do focus groups
uh with teens and i never realized prior
to the pandemic
how struggling uh they were struggling
they were hurting their anxiety their
stress even though they were loved to
death their opportunities were endless
but something was really amiss with the
kids and then the pandemic hit well a
crisis only amplifies a pre-existing
issue and therefore the cdc and the
surging general's reports on mental
health needs are critical but it also
means hey folks we've got to reset what
we're doing here we have to reset what
we're thinking and this is um when i
wrote the last one thrivers was empathy
was what i did was to choose the seven
most highly correlated strengths that
research in all the work on resilience
says are teachable that will impact
mental health resilience and peak
performance of course number two on the
list was empathy because i don't think
you can go anywhere without empathy but
the first on the list was confidence
the child needs to know who they are
what their passion is that we talked
about earlier and we've driven that
passion out of it many kids said we're
being driven to be what my parents want
me to be
not who i am i think that's so essential
the third one we already talked about
too is self-control unless you can
figure out how to put the brake on
impulses and do that one two breath or
whatever works for you
a fourth is integrity that would be what
samuel linder discovered those parents
knew exactly what the kind of kid they
wanted to turn out of that house in this
house we're gonna have be kind we're
gonna be caring we're gonna be socially
responsible
empathy and social responsible were the
two highest correlated values of a home
that raises a kid who's altruist wow but
they kept going out over and over again
uh and then the fifth one is curiosity
we've helicoptered our kids to death
we've solved every problem for them
there goes the agency
so curiosity is helping the kid be
creative and open to ideas and
possibilities so when the challenge
comes you're not dumbf you figure out
what am i going to do instead
mom's not going to help me this time
she's going to teach me how to
brainstorm
what's the problem what's one thing you
could have done differently and another
thing
50 60s perseverance now you're going to
keep on going because you've got all
these other little skills along the way
and you're going to realize your effort
is what gets you moving not
your gpa or your zip code and the final
one is optimism and hope
we don't instill that in a child
particularly in today's world and the
images that they're seeing
after a while a lot of them are going to
start raising a white flag of i
surrender why should i do it and i give
up that's not the kind of child we want
we want a strong kid who knows the world
is going to be okay
and uh there's things that you can do to
make it okay yeah and again just back up
by all the research and tying that full
circle especially any with that hope as
you mentioned before too
i mean there's so many so many good
things that you're doing i think there's
a lot that the listeners will be able to
digest here and to re-listen to as well
and you've talked about this right but
i'm curious you know with all these
efforts what's the what's the the piece
that brings you the most joy
in this work
the kids
have it's i i didn't realize because i
was the like you
the the person that was just reading the
research and research off to the side
i've got a pile this big and i just keep
reading it reading and then i go and
talk to the kids and then go my gosh
that's exactly what the research said
it's like why don't we just talk to the
kids and they also have solutions
simple little things that they suggest
and so um there isn't a time when i can
be exhausted getting off a plane but if
i know i'm going to do a focus group i
get rejuvenated going
that's the next generation and there's
hope yeah yeah in some ways i mean even
ty i'm tying back to your dad again too
but you're building community in so many
ways with all the lives that you're
touching it really just makes me think
about the way that people invested in
your dad and what you're doing for
others in the community you're building
around that so
well um
it's been a joy it's still a ride and
the more you turn on the news you
realize this is more relevant now than
ever
uh we i i think the piece that if
there's one takeaway here
resilience is not a program and one
trait i see that a lot it's not locked
into your dna this is something that
research says can be done it isn't an
overnight process either so we can all
relax this is a new thing of a new
parenting and educational plan that
we've got to weave in and we weave it
into not like at six o'clock when you
talk about resilience but we weave it
into our discipline the books we read
the talks we have with our kids
we just need to be a little more
intentional and yeah so this is
important and we can do it find one
little tip you want to weave in and do
that every day a minute a day and i
think that's how we start raising
stronger kids yeah that's so well said
that intentionality and as you emphasize
throughout one step at a time not
everything at once but just really being
able to bake it in in a sense
and well as a final question this has
been a joy just having you here for your
inspiration and encouragement where can
people go to find out more resources
either about you your books or just
resources in general around these topics
um well my my website is
michelleborba.com i'm a 1l michelle and
borbo runs to zorba so there you go
uh thrivers is the latest book that will
be out in paperback um march 8th in in
digital form audio form uh also
paperback so it's
i think what i tried to do is make this
nugget proof kind of simple stuff so
never hopefully read an entire book of
mine in one sitting instead crack it
open
there's a test at the beginning of which
of those strengths is your children's
strengths or weaknesses
you see it as a weakness but you see it
as there's where i'm going to start and
then just keep looking at it as one
particular ongoing plan the other thing
i think we do wrong is we try to do it
ourselves
get a grandmother involved get the
daycare worker involved pass it on to
the teacher here's the one little thing
i'm working on this month and you'll
always optimize your gains with your
child
yeah great advice great advice
well thank you so much for being here on
the addi hour for all the uh
encouragement and inspiration and this
is the practical tips that you share
with our listeners too i know this is
one that people will be grateful for and
i think you're going to be able to share
with others and also listen to a few
times to catch catch all these nuances
and some of these practical tips as well
so thanks so much for being here thank
you yes do you stay well you too
[Music]